In Iraq, the cleanup begins after another day of bombings in Baghdad.
Nearly 2,000 Iraqis have been killed in the last three months.
In the US, gay couples and their supporters in California...
...celebrate the Supreme Court rulings on same-sex marriage.
In South Africa, the daughter of Nelson Mandela says the family still has hope,...
...as well-wishers continue vigil outside his hospital.
In Gaza, a UN report says only five to ten percent of the territory's water is safe to drink...
...due to contamination by sewage, chemicals, and seawater.
In Portugal, a general strike against austerity measures brings commuter services to a halt.
And finally from Italy, bad times for Berlusconi,...
...the former prime minister convicted of sex with an underage girl,...
...now faces corruption charges.